I feel this question is for Whitney she
could hook up with one current Comedy
Store comedian a regular together would
that be just to have sex with or to our
goal is this to have sex quit stalking
her mr. Hall or continue stocking man
Add to Cart download Michelle Joey Diaz
maybe would be good I love Joey dia is
this just have sex with there's just
like marry anymore I think these days it
just means that hookup to me means like
the one I want to marry [ __ ] out of here
so sad as sad as that I don't do that I
like I was with I was like played so I
was like they have a good credit score I
love Joey Diaz that's feel so weird
because it feels like incest to me like
comics to me right so platonic
so say even a platonic husband ship that
you had to be in someone with oh god
this is gonna get me in trouble I feel
it Bryan Callen Wow I mean Bryan makes
me laugh right oh yeah Bryan makes me
laugh
he says this gift it's almost like you
ever seen Tinkerbell like um it's like
Tinker Bell's like inside of him you
know like you know Robin Hood has Tinker
Bell well you know what it is it's like
Robin Hood oh yeah yeah Peter Pan yeah
that's on their shoulder he's just
always like yeah he's always ready like
he doesn't even [ __ ] sleep it's like
he just hides behind a piece of ice on
like a gesture yes you know he's like I
you know I think that a big part of
being a comic by the way I do did have a
self tanner Fiasco so I'm worried people
are looking at my hand nobody can see us
I hear like this isn't recording you
[ __ ] idiot I think such a big part of
being a stand-up is making the audience
feel like they're safe with you right
right like you're in good hands right
you know and when you trip up or you're
like looking at your notes all of a
sudden they're like oh oh like this
person might not know what they're doing
they might not be in control yeah like
they might have a sense of doubt like
when you start giving the audience power
yeah that's what people like oh you guys
don't think that's funny whatever I'm
always like don't do that cuz then
you're giving them power yeah and
all of a sudden the the curtain has been
pulled away and they're in charge you
work for them now right and Talon when
you're around Callen you're just like ah
I know I'm not going to do any work
right yeah
he's just gonna [ __ ] do gymnastics
he's planking yeah his dicks out he's
like it's you know you doing pull-ups
like he's easy I know that I can just
sit on the bench his dicks I was doing
Romeo and Juliet I remember he's doing
an impression of a bird he's on this
hanging from the ceiling he's spider now
he's an endangered species like I could
just get to go on a vacation I don't
have to even have a conversation because
he's gonna do some [ __ ] vagina
monologue like I just have to do it's
just the so I could live with someone
like that where I feel like I do
I'm just being served me too I could be
in it I could be in a platonic three-way
marriage with you and Bryan Callen who
would you would you date have you ever
dated comment no Schumer and I dated for
a little bit that's true yeah I didn't
know that yes he and I did right before
a movie came out and it wasn't I don't
know yeah between us on a set its didn't
fit didn't she didn't leave me I just
hidden it I didn't have trust in her
like she always liked one of me you a
boyfriend and girlfriend exclusive I
don't know oh I don't know I felt like I
just was like at a certain point I felt
like was a little bit of like a puppet
kind of like kind of just like a little
sex puppet you know nicer is that like
every guy's dream
but it wasn't my dream no you know kind
of I don't they had it but she used like
this I she didn't use what we talked
about like his bigger idea like this
bigger kind of thing you know so of what
being together in a bigger way yeah and
she would like bring it up some hey what
I mean it was like maybe three or four
months you know but we'd always been
sweet on each other for a long time like
we've been like sweet on each other's
like a decade cuz we did a show for
Comedy Central together a long time ago
other one Bert yeah hey Bert Tiffany
Haddish I remember I just remember that
show cuz I remember one day Bert
Kreischer showed up at the improv or
something he was like sweating and he
was all red and I was like you know
what's going on he's like I just drank
two bottles of soy sauce I was like what
show is that that's so Bert still sober
yeah I mean he switched condiments but
same bird yeah
I just drank too bad the whole can of
wasabi like know the show wrapped 6
months ago just do it now
out of my thing that's my sigh Alice
yeah just epic pin myself Redmond okay
so you dated comics for real a bunch
really though she was really only it
yeah you know but yeah it just wasn't I
don't know she's a little more
emotionally efficient than I am say that
I got any difference she's more
emotionally efficient what does that
mean like motions are inherently not
efficient right right
for me they're not you know for me it's
more of like a UH you mean she could
navigate them more easily than you know
she just like knows what she wants
emotion I'm knows what she wants it but
to the point for for my speed it wasn't
it wasn't a comfortable speed
understanding yeah I understand it was
just I'm such a robot I just want
understanding yeah that's like what a
robot would say understanding processing
scary like the idea of dating a cut like
so you're not intimidated by a woman who
does comedy I think a lot of guys don't
love it no I'm not no I'm not I think
though I wonder like it when it gets to
like the sense of like having a family
and kids and like a month more of like
having a motherly environment be around
your like to be home when you're out why
don't want somebody with that [ __ ]
you know that Siberian womb but you know
what hat is that mean old no just means
kind of chorused yeah definitely briskly
know like people hiking in the distance
my interests are far away there's some
sleigh dogs like I don't want you know
the epidemic of dating someone who after
you break up becomes a comedian hmm or
during their relationship with you
decides they want to start comedy is a
ramp yeah I dated two guys like two
years ago that Natalie woke up all of a
sudden they're like at flappers oh yeah
correct
yes do you think you had that I know see
and I know the guys name was Mike oh my
god no but like also what I know a lot
of guys who are dating girl and I don't
know if it's chicken or egg I don't know
if they they start dating me because
they want to be comics and they want to
learn how to
do it or if halfway through I somehow
make it look so [ __ ] easy that's like
I can do that like I don't know but I
know a lot of guys who date girls and
halfway through they're like I think I
want to start comedy do you think that
they feel like if they're not funny
enough or they're not in that world that
you're not gonna want to be with them no
I think they just general genuinely see
that like how you know they're like she
just goes 20 minutes a night ya know
this it makes money like this should be
a little harder she can do it I can
[ __ ] do it or it's my fault I blame
myself because I think I I learned early
on you have to laugh at a guy's jokes
even if you don't think they're funny
because I'm always trying to make sure
you know what I mean like that I'm not
somebody okay so yeah so guys would be
corny and I'm like you're hilarious
I probably enabled it like Whitney
thinks I'm funny I'm yeah do that thing
were you juggling now I'm like getting
bombed
getting bumped by my eggs [ __ ] ha
people just getting molested in the back
and there's suddenly a [ __ ] they got
lotteries that's so person did you ever
date any company he said you didn't I
haven't dated any comics but you're
starting them you're starting them yeah
I've done like a manage I'm a
developmental executive at this point
I'm just a talent yeah I give my man 10%
for all these guys but yeah who knows I
don't know I think there's there is
something extremely attractive about
somebody that can make you laugh I think
but it's also for me like it's just like
don't [ __ ] where you eat and like it's
already so hard to do stand-up the only
thing that would make it worse if you
had to like run into your act oh yeah in
the belly room like working on new
material or like having your ex be like
some book in this girl last night it's
like wasn't that good idea were you ever
there when Gary Gulman in April Macie
got in a huge fight at Westwood Berko
when he was on stage I think that's when
I was like I'm never dating comic
[ __ ] ever I love April
I just I love oh yeah I love I think
she's hilarious me too her story about
her mom and stuff is so he's he's really
funny too I just haven't seen a lot of
him letting everything go yeah you know
Gary Gulman in partying no I've never
seen me watch yeah this [ __ ]
just 40 minutes on sugar cookies like
how is he coming up with it like it's
amazing he did like an hour on orange
juice like how have you brushed your
teeth mr. Gore's yeah like he's
beautiful yeah he's like Jimmy Schubert
a little bit it's like this weird art
and he's like six four and like it lying
back her body like and he does jokes
about like [ __ ] you know slim jims
how is it so he's like anyway so is it
Westwood bruco one night I can't believe
you weren't there this was tender and
all the shitty nights I was there the
one that one were you miss and he was on
stage and like two people in the
audience and april/may she was like wait
I don't know how it happened but she was
extreme it was amazing but I was like
I'm never dating a comic that's what
it's gonna turn into can you imagine the
only thing worse than fighting with your
boyfriend or girlfriend is doing it in
front of college kids and other comics
at 1:00 a.m. on a Tuesday and they don't
know either one is like well these
fuck-ups I think April they're not
together anymore she know we're going to
hell everybody the whole group oh can
you imagine like if I was in a fight
with my ex and I was about to go on and
like work on new material and then he
[ __ ] shows up with his girlfriend
what great was here he'd get out of it
can you imagine that
I would lose my [ __ ] [ __ ] did you
ever see when Mark Marin and um David
I've gotten a fight in the oh I didn't
date Wow
wild dove was on state or while Mark was
on stage and then they got in a big
fight yeah that's the kind of [ __ ] that
where you're just like you know what
this is worth it like one day I'll be
able to tell that story yeah I've had to
listen to mark down it's been hectic
sometimes
I want to yelled at them were you there
the night I yelled I feel like we missed
like four years I feel like we missed
every [ __ ] year I feel like we have
never we never really have crossed that
there the night that I yelled and all
the Comedy Store comics and told them to
class it up it says a Connecticut thing
this somebody from Frank I lost my [ __ ]
one night because it does take a toll on
you like there were no female comics
with Tommy's drop for so long and it was
like me and like 10 dudes you know and
like I was in bad relationship after a
bad relationship and I think I had maybe
so a guy was with a cheat or not yeah I
think we had broken up and he'd just
like slept with someone like the next
day or something and I was angry anyway
and like yesterday I didn't have the
grit and I went in and I saw like
someone was there and talking about a
brought a girl that a different girl
from the night before like I don't think
I've done anything wrong but I just
snapped like an triggered me and like I
have all sorts of dyke at Westwood bruco
know in the parking lot I'll do you need
a glass at all everyone needs a closin
up around like I snapped like um I was
talking to my dad but I had to take it
out on you know the [ __ ] oor hallway
everybody I screamed at it's just dark
out there in the park what did they say
so how was the fallout I think they
learned pretty I think they understood
that it was like my [ __ ] and then it was
just it was taking a toll on me to see
these single guys every night living the
way they live which is like no judgement
I think I was it was starting to like
just wear on me I think it was part of
the reason I also leave so fast cuz I'm
like I don't want to see your eyes I
don't wanna see any of that [ __ ] do you
feel like you want to see guys be better
than they are
judgement like if you're not raping
anybody like if you're cheating that's
your business that's between you and
your wife that's not cheating is not
illegal right
like if you're my friend and I think you
love your wife and I know you're gonna
lose her like that's a bummer right
maybe I'll say something or if you have
kids but now like and if you're famous
like you know a lot of people's jobs are
at stake you know and and so I'll feel
bad but it's not my business you know
it's not my business but that night I
just lost it mmm because I think that
the problem is being around okay but
also guys think of me as like a
bro so guys what you're just smash this
chick last night I was like don't tell
me like really [ __ ] up my paradigm of
the world right you know it's not
healthy for me to hear that all the time
yeah cuz I have to go out in date guys
yeah I want to hear like the how the
sausage is spinning yeah yes I skirt was
like it was like dove and I met and oh
yeah oh my Kyung I remember that
memorize it so ladies membra that is the
Bermuda Triangle
a vagina will go missing on between
those three men that is a Bermuda
Triangle I don't even he's like hey
everybody remember I think it was there
was somebody I think it was like I'll
magical came in and I was like oh your
God like it was like yeah you sell shoes
you're cool with me the rest of you I
literally was I don't even want to raise
my arm suddenly show me something I was
doing a helicopter I was like we need a
class it up in the parking lot like
Petey Pablo
it was a bad batshit crazy I mean no no
one has spoken of it since and no one
even has the audacity to like make fun
of it or bring it up because it's just
$2.00 iguana it's gonna be called the
guano episode that [ __ ]
those were the days of the store where
it was like [ __ ] was so nuts I was crazy
I remember I would go over like 1:00 in
the morning I learned a lot though there
was one time this actually changed my
life I had just I think it was around
the same time max I was going through
some [ __ ] and we're in the audience and
like 1:00 in the morning there was this
woman in the audience like three like
black women in the back and I was
talking about like it like I was having
a real moment I would just go onstage
and like read text messages to the
audience picture I respond to this guy
like I was just like so anybody can be
in there it was 1:00 in the morning it
wasn't about comedy I would just
literally go up like one person was a
hat maker that's who was on stage I'm
like what oh do you remember there was a
fight remember that time burn and and
bread urns got in a fight in the or the
Audis someone charged Steve burn while
he was on stage and they caught the guy
and this was back before food there was
no food there was no food
no audience it would used to walk on
stage you like trip over and share yeah
you'd come off stage and just fall so
dangerous emotionally physically all of
it there's no food I don't think it's
even drink people brought in brown paper
bags okay we're just saving spitting
they're like makers if you were making
water in the back pain there was like oh
there was no men in women's room it was
like [ __ ] [ __ ] his people holding
each other off of a back dock pissing
into the law nightmare and then one time
I was on stage and a bombing at 1:00 in
the morning and I was like you guys this
guy he didn't call me back what should I
do and this woman just went [ __ ] she
yelled at me
they had no respect for the Cobbers
[ __ ] silence is the only language men
understand I was like yeah like it was
like a pep rally really it was like an
inspirational I don't know crazy it was
crazy